RAKESH DHOOPAR: First of
all, I want to welcome you
to Google Next 2021.
In this session, I
will focus on what role
integrated
observability tools play
in helping developing teams
become elite-performing teams.
So without further
delay, let's get started.
My name is Rakesh Dhoopar.
I'm a Director of Product
Management at Google.
I focus on our products
related to cloud observability.
In today's session, I
will touch on five areas.
First, I will start
by talking about,
what do we mean by the term,
"elite-performing teams?"
While transformation towards
becoming an elite team usually
requires a wide variety
of changes, including
adhering to certain
operational principles,
evolving operational
processes, and adopting
a variety of tools,
in this session,
I will focus on
observability tools only.
We call our offering for
observability the Cloud Ops
Suite.
I will then dive
deeper into some
of the specific capabilities
that help developers
and operators
reduce the time they
need to spend on identifying,
diagnosing, and troubleshooting
problems.
Now, this part of
the talk will focus
on how we make it
easier to instrument
and collect telemetry signals
and analyze them effectively
to improve troubleshooting.
Lastly, I will talk about how
developers and operators can
overcome friction
between the two teams
so that they can move fast
while maintaining reliability
of their services.
So let me first start
by defining what we mean
by the term, "elite teams."
And to illustrate that, I will
refer to a quote from the Dora
report.
So some of you may be wondering,
what is the Dora report?
Now, at its very foundation Dora
is an ongoing research program
sponsored by Google.
It is the largest and
longest-running research
program of its kind.
The research program
collects and analyzes data
from over 30,000
practitioners and analyzes
the practices that drive
their software delivery
and operations performance.
Participating
organizations are measured
on metrics for
software development,
metrics for software
deployment, and metrics
for service operations.
From this collected
data, we then
do cluster analysis to
benchmark organizations
against the industry and
identify characteristics
that are grouped into cohorts
for low, medium, high,
and elite performers.
Elite teams are the highest
performers on at least one
of the metrics measured
for either software
development, software
deployment, or service
operations.
Now, one of the most interesting
findings from this research
is that many professionals
approach these metrics
as representing a
set of trade-offs.
Now, these professionals believe
that increasing throughput
of software development
will negatively
impact the availability and
reliability of their services.
However, to the
contrary, this research
has consistently shown,
for the last six years,
that speed and stability are
outcome that enable each other.
Simply stated,
elite performers are
able to move fast and
deploy their code rapidly
without compromising
on service reliability.
The research also
found that elite teams
were able to deploy
multiple times
a day, while low performers
were deploying less than once
per month.
Now, at the same time,
these elite performers
had a time to restore a
service of less than one hour,
while the low performers
reported between one week
to one month.
I'm going to briefly talk about
one of our customers in more
detail, and that
customer is Lowe's.
So Lowe's is one of the largest
do-it-yourself home improvement
retailer in the United States.
Now, as a part of their
digital transformation efforts,
they decided to modernize
some of their applications
using Google Cloud.
Now, as they went through
this business transformation,
they worked closely with Google
to transform their organization
from a traditional
IT ops organization
to an SRE-type organization.
For their observability
tools, they
picked our cloud-native
capabilities offered
by the Cloud Operations Suite.
When they embarked on this
journey in 2019, in early 2020,
they had to accelerate
this transformation effort.
The pandemic forced
more and more customers
to transact online.
And they had to integrate
these cloud-native apps
with pricing systems
that were running
on prem and with many store
best inventory systems
so that they could
fulfill customer orders
from a particular store
in a timely manner.
Then, during the Black
Friday, Cyber Monday period,
their transaction volume
increased by 3 times
of their already
high daily volume.
Lowe's handled the
entire workload
and their observability
challenges without any hiccups.
The results they shared
with us were simply amazing.
They were able to
reduce their mean time
to acknowledge from 30 minutes
to 1 minute, their mean time
to restore a service from
2 hours to 20 minutes,
while increasing their
development velocity by 300x.
They were able to move
from one monolithic release
every two weeks to
20-plus releases a day.
Now, that's quite a story.
So let's dive into the
observability tools offering
from Google.
Collectively, we call these
capabilities Cloud Operations
Suite.
Cloud Operations Suite is
Google's observability solution
that was designed for scale.
It includes Cloud
Monitoring, Cloud Logging,
and advanced
observability tools.
Cloud Monitoring
captures and analyzes
system and application metrics.
It also enables users
to define and monitor
service-level objectives.
And it automatically tracks
corresponding error budgets.
Cloud Logging offers users the
ability to aggregate system
and application logs,
and explore these logs
with an intuitive
log explorer UI.
Our advanced observability
tools include Cloud Trace.
And that enables users to track
how requests are propagating
through your applications
or microservices
and receive detailed
real-time insights.
Now, it is important to
highlight the Cloud Logging
and Monitoring are both
built on the same platform
that Google uses internally
for its SRE operations.
Now, as a result, as
your applications scale,
you don't have to
worry about scaling
your observability tools.
Google Cloud Logging processes
about 2 and 1/2 exabytes
of log data every month.
Now, while most
enterprises may not
require that level
of scalability,
you should feel comfortable
that logging and monitoring
systems will be able
to scale not if,
but when your business
needs suddenly change
and you witness an order
of magnitude more users
or are faced with any kind
of cloud burst use cases.
And that has actually happened
with several of our customers.
And I will share a
couple of examples here.
Gannett, a media company
that owns "USA Today,"
they saw an order of
magnitude higher number
of users on election
night, 2020 in the US.
In another example, one
of our gaming customers
saw their users expand
overnight every time they
launched new games.
So they have easily seen more
than a million users join over
a very short period of time.
And in both cases,
the customers were
able to scale
their applications,
and along with
those applications,
their observability solutions.
Similarly, our
monitoring service
is also based on a highly
scalable time series platform.
When applications are
monolithic and deployed
on a small number
of named servers,
the volume of metrics
and monitoring tools
was not very high.
Now, with the move to Kubernetes
and microservices-based
architectures, the number of
components generating metrics
has gone way up.
In some instances, we have
seen that metric volumes
have actually gone up
by almost 100 times.
Also, because of the ephemeral
nature of components,
the granularity of
metrics has shifted
from 1-minute
collection frequency
down to 10-second
collection frequency.
And sometimes, even down to
1-second collection frequency.
All of these have created
extremely high requirements
on scaling the underlying
time series platforms.
And we want to make sure that we
provide a platform that scales
to meet your toughest
scaling requirements.
So with that
high-level overview,
let us first look
at how users can
instrument their
applications and collect
telemetry signals from
systems and applications that
are running on GCP.
Instrumentation and data
collection have always
been a challenge in IT.
And we have seen a proliferation
of agents over the past two
decades.
Google has been a strong
proponent of open standards.
And we've been actively
driving OpenTelemetry standard
for service instrumentation
and signal collection.
Now, as the standards
evolve and mature,
we have been adopting
it in our products
to make it easier for
developers to instrument
their applications.
The OpenTelemetry standard
consists of three key things.
A, language-specific API
and SDK for developers
to instrument
their applications.
B, the OpenTelemetry
collector and receivers
for collecting signals.
And C, the
OpenTelemetry exporter
for sending data to different
vendors for storage,
visualization, and alerting.
We're currently working on
instrumenting our client
libraries with OpenTelemetry,
starting with the gRPC library.
We believe that as the
OpenTelemetry standards mature
across all three
signal types, it
will provide huge
benefits for developers
to start instrumenting
their applications
from the very beginning,
rather than wait for incidents
to happen and then have
the operations team define
what needs to be instrumented
in the application.
Secondly, to provide
out-of-the-box support
for OpenTelemetry, we recently
released the unified ops agent.
The unified ops
agent makes it easier
to install, configure, and
upgrade the collection agent.
This unified agent combines
the monitoring and logging
agent into one
installable component,
and provides a single YAML-based
configuration language.
We're migrating our
third-party application
stack monitoring
plugins to become
OpenTelemetry-based receivers.
And those should be available
through the rest of this year.
Now, Prometheus is a very
popular open-source monitoring
service in Kubernetes
environments.
Now, in the spirit of openness
and support for open source,
we support and integrate
with Prometheus in two ways.
First, we have integrations
with the Prometheus engine
to make it easier for users
to ingest Kubernetes metrics
and workload metrics
from Prometheus to Cloud
Monitoring and leverage the
rich capabilities in Cloud
Monitoring.
That includes alerting,
dashboarding, and metric query
language.
Second, we recently announced
the Google-managed Prometheus
service for users who want
to continue using Prometheus,
but do not want to stand
up the infrastructure
behind Prometheus on
their own, and then
manage the Prometheus service.
Now, for GKE environments
specifically, we
have made signal
collection even easier.
One of the key
benefits of Cloud Ops
is that users do
not have to deploy
any agents for
collecting metrics
and logs in GKE environments.
Not only does this reduce
the toil of deploying agents,
this is very critical in
Kubernetes environments,
because the containers
are ephemeral.
And in some cases,
the containers
may have very short lifespans,
as they are automatically
scaled up and down
based on policies.
This automatic collection
includes key metrics
for a variety of GKE objects,
including nodes, pods,
and clusters.
In addition to the
system logs, application
logs that are written
with standard out
and standard error
are automatically
collected as well.
Now, more importantly,
the preconfigured agent
automatically
captures metadata and
the hierarchical relationships
amongst all of the Kubernetes
objects, from clusters to
nodes to services, all the way
to pods and containers.
As we will see later,
these relationships
come in very handy
when users are
exploring observability data
for diagnosing problems.
Let us now briefly look
at what capabilities
we provide for signal
analysis and visualization.
As part of the Cloud Ops Suite,
we offer an out-of-the-box GKE
dashboard.
The dashboard provides a very
rich and powerful experience
that was purpose-built for GKE.
The dashboard aggregates
all metrics, logs,
service-level objectives,
Kubernetes events, and alerts
into one place for all
of your GKE clusters.
Entities and their data,
presented in this dashboard,
are related to each other using
the context graph that I talked
about on the previous slide.
When the context graph
is not visible in the UI,
when you start filtering
data in this dashboard,
the presence of the context
graph becomes evident.
The filtering is not just a
text or label-based filtering,
but the filtering
in this dashboard
happens based on the
relationships in the context
graph.
So for example, when users
filter for a specific cluster,
only objects that
belong to that cluster
will be shown in the dashboard.
Each section of the
dashboard, from namespace
to node to service, will
be filtered based on
whether or not they belong
to the specific cluster.
Similarly, when a user filters
based on the name of a pod,
again, all the objects that
are not related to this pod
will be filtered out.
Only the cluster, the
namespace, the node,
and the service that
this pod belongs to
will be shown in the dashboard.
Now, this is extremely powerful.
And a lot of work
has actually gone
into scaling this
kind of filtering
and presenting all of this
data in an aggregated manner.
Cloud Operations offers
purpose-built explorers
for each of the three
different types of signals.
Namely, metrics,
logs, and traces.
So for metrics, we offer
the Metrics Explorer
for analyzing time series
data for creating charts
as well as for adding
these charts to a dashboard
For advanced metric analysis,
we offer the metric query
language, which provides a
powerful query-based mechanism
to manipulate this
time series data.
Using these queries, users
can compute ratios of metrics.
Users can perform
time-shift analysis.
Users can analyze
arbitrary percentiles.
And users can evaluate arbitrary
mathematical expressions
on this time series data.
Similarly the Logs Explorer
was purpose-built for analyzing
logs.
The Logs Explorer provides
a histogram view that
helps users analyze log trends.
Writing log analysis
queries can be tedious.
So we've made it a lot easier to
create, save, and share queries
for analyzing these logs.
For richer analysis
of log data, users
can extract and analyze
fields from log data,
as well as define
streaming alerts
on individual log events.
Logs can also be
converted into metrics.
And then, users can leverage
all of the capabilities
available in Cloud Monitoring,
which includes visualization,
learning, dashboarding,
or defining SLOs
on these logs-based metrics.
Lastly, the Trace Explorer
provides an interface
that makes it easy to visualize
all traces and associated
latencies, filter
traces of interest
based on different criteria,
and define alerts on trace data
so that users can do
behavioral comparison of how
the latency of a specific
trace compares over time.
While GKE Dashboard provides a
curated and tailored experience
for GKE-based apps,
many customers
still need to build
custom dashboards.
We did quite an extensive
amount of UEX research
over the past year
to understand what
users need when they're actually
creating these dashboards.
Based on that research, we
have created a pretty intuitive
experience for creating and
editing custom dashboards.
There's a variety
of new chart types,
dynamically re-sizable
charts, easy way
to drag and drop
editing on a dashboard,
as well as use the full power
of the metrics query language
within the dashboard itself
to explore the data before you
add it to a dashboard.
Now, one of the
interesting chart
types we've added recently
is the Alert chart type.
When a user adds this
chart to the dashboard,
they can also associate an
alert policy with that chart.
And users can then see
the alert threshold
from that policy on this chart.
Finally, to automate the
creation of dashboards
we have populated
a GitHub repository
with over 60
dashboard templates,
and a Terraform module to
automate the deployment
of these templates.
In addition, we recently added
a sample dashboard capability
directly into the
product UI that
makes it easy to ingest and
adapt these sample dashboards
from the GitHub repository.
Users can get a preview of
each of these dashboards
without any effort before they
start adapting and adopting
these sample dashboards.
Let us finally look at
how development teams can
become elite-performing teams.
And the most important thing
we will discuss in this section
is, how the two teams can
collaborate amongst each other.
Well, the collaboration between
development and ops teams
can be improved by
defining and measuring
service-level objectives.
That is easier said than done.
To improve that
collaboration, we
recommend that both
developers and operators
have a seat at the design table
early on in the software design
process so they can agree
to a common language,
agree on a best way to
measure reliability,
and create reliability as a
shared objective for the two
teams.
Now, once they have agreed to
the service-level indicators
and what service-level
objectives
they want to achieve, they can
then use these capabilities
within the Service Monitoring
feature in Cloud Operations.
Cloud Monitoring-- or
Service Monitoring--
will automatically
and continuously
keep track of how
the teams are doing
with respect to the agreed SLO.
The error budget
is automatically
computed and tracked as well.
As long as the error budget
for a given time period
has not been
exhausted, developers
can move with full
velocity to continue
pushing out new capabilities.
However, as the error budget
gets close to exhaustion,
the mechanism becomes
self-regulating.
New features are slowed
down, and both developers
and operator shifts towards
improving the service
reliability.
Now, as organizations
improve the collaboration
between developers and
operators around SLOs,
they also need to adopt
some best practices
that we have shared.
These best practices
include A, accepting
that failure is normal and
not striving towards 100% SLO.
B, measuring everything,
including toil and reliability,
and using automation and
observability tools to reduce
toil so developers and
operators can contribute
towards feature velocity.
Lastly, when an
incident does happen,
we recommend that
the two teams strive
towards blameless
postmortems and drive service
reliability improvements.
Let us look at how
customers can use service
monitoring to
adopt and implement
some of these SRE principles.
The service monitoring
capabilities
enables users to select
a service-level indicator
and define the
service-level objectives.
Now, once the SLO is
defined, Cloud Monitoring
will automatically compute
and track error budgets.
Users can also define alerts
on these error budgets.
So as you reach a critical
threshold on your error budget,
alerts will be generated.
And users will be notified about
the exhaustion of the error
budget.
For GKE services, there
is further out-of-the-box
integration that makes it easier
to define the service-level
objectives.
Cloud Ops will
automatically discover
services that are using Istio
and ASM deployed on GKE.
So when a user defines an
SLO for these auto-discovered
services, if they choose an
availability or latency metric,
Cloud Ops will automatically
pick or recommend the metric
to be used as a
service-level indicator.
Now, since some customers
choose Prometheus to monitor
Kubernetes services--
and specifically, their
apps running in Kubernetes--
we also provide out-of-the-box
integration for such customers
to ingest metrics from
Prometheus and be able
to define SLIs and SLOs
on Prometheus metrics.
Of course, users can
define custom services
or choose any other custom
metric to use as an SLI,
and then define an
SLO on that metric.
So let me summarize some of the
key highlights from this talk.
First, what we have seen from
the analysis in the Dora report
and from the customer
example I talked about.
Elite teams can achieve
high feature velocity
without sacrificing
service reliability.
Two, from a tools point
of view, Cloud Operations
offers integrated capabilities
that brings together the three
different signals
to make it easier
to improve MTGR and
enable developers and SRE
users to focus on
increasing code velocity.
Three, elite teams
use SLIs and SLOs
as a mechanism to formalize
reliability targets
between developers
and operators.
And customers can use
these capabilities
within Cloud Operations.
If you're interested in more
sessions around this topic
or interested in learning about
our Cloud Operations Suite,
there are three additional
sessions listed on this slide.
And I welcome you
to go watch those.
Please enjoy those
sessions and other sessions
in the Next 2021.
And thank you again for
attending this session.